bonjour jallet l'achat oui merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france les deux parties
doivent donc signé les modalités de
l'accord de cessez-le-feu quelles sont
ses modalités
là le but c'est surtout de monde
d'envoyer une image de projeter de cette
cérémonie qui va avoir lieu de manière
très surprenante surprenante pour les
européens qui pensaient pouvoir avoir la
mainmise sur la diplomatie relatives au
conflit libyen
donc l'objectif ce matin s'est montrée
la disposition de trois grands acteurs
libyens le maréchal haftar le premier
ministre sa rage est aussi le président
du parlement de tobrouk à gué la salle
vont venir à moscou et cela quelques
jours après l'échec de une cérémonie
similaire qui devait se tenir à rome
donc ça c'est ça l'objectif c'est pas
forcément la profondeur de l'accord les
détails vont sans doute être sans aucun
doute être finalisé en tout cas avancé
un petit peu à berlin on voit donc
espèce de transmission de tâches entre
la libertine et angela merkel encore une
fois l'objectif ce matin ce n'est pas
forcément la continuation du cessez le
feu qui n'a pas été très bien l'observer
hier j'ai je pense qu'il va y avoir des
incidents encore plus graves aujourd'hui
même si évidemment l'intensité du
conflit est plus basse j'insiste
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas tellement la
sophistication où la profondeur de
l'accord mais simplement le fait de voir
que moscou continue à bien coordonner
avec la turquie acceptent la turquie en
même temps les émirati accepte le rôle
russe malgré son partenariat avec la
turquie et on va voir comme ça la russie
émergé comme un centre de médiation
ça ne veut pas dire la paix d'une
manière très concrète pour les habitants
civile par exemple de la zone de tripoli
il s'agit surtout d'une cérémonie est
d'envoyer des symboles les symboles qui
sont d'abord et avant tout la
signification d'un échec diplomatique
européen vous avez parlé de berlin 5 un
gala merkel a rencontré vladimir poutine
samedi dernier à moscou
cette trêve vous l'avez dit elle a donc
été demandé par vladimir poutine et
richie paper douanes c'était mercredi
dernier
mais quel rôle exactement jouent moscou
et ankara
et est ce que les puissances
occidentales sont elles hors jeu
vraiment c'est ça que vous voulez dire
vous avez parlé de l'italie et de la
france également
d'un point de vue diplomatique oui de
manière absolument certaine il y à un
glissement qui est en train de se faire
il y avait il ya quelques mois une
complaisance extrême qui explique la
lenteur par exemple du processus de
berlin où la france pensait avoir le
luxe de pouvoir contredire son ami
allemand
qu'est ce qui se passe là il ya d'abord
l'intervention militaire surtout affirmé
d'un point de vue rhétorique mais
néanmoins réelle de la turquie et ses
tables sa présence militaire se traduit
pour un poids diplomatique que tous les
états sont obligés aujourd'hui
d'accepter les européens ont choisi de
condamner la turquie et la russie a
décidé de se montrer beaucoup plus
pragmatique d'utiliser son partenariat
je parle pas d'amitié mais son
partenariat sont en entente avec la
turquie pour justement pour suivre cette
conversation qui acceptent le poids
turque dans l'ouest libyen
et comme je le disais tout à l'heure les
états du golfe qui exige une amitié
exclusive de la part de la france par
exemple n'existe pas la même chose
auprès de vladimir poutine vladimir
poutine continue d'être un interlocuteur
significatif que tous les acteurs dans
ce théâtre là cherchent à courtiser à
conserver et donc les états du golfe et
surtout les émirati qui sont la terre
fait rare le plus le plus massif en
libye est bien de leur part il ya aussi
une acceptation de cette émergence russe
donc pour l'instant c'est de la
diplomatie qui se traduit pas par une
paix concrètes mais on voit bien un
nouveau schéma diplomatique qui signifie
l'exclusion de tous les acteurs
européens et y compris
l'union européenne qui oblige est
maintenant de suivre après être s'être
enfermé dans la condamnation totale de
la turquie sans nous mais les autres
interférence étrangère
merci j'allais là harchaoui d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste de la libye et
chercheur à l'institut clingendael de la
haye aux pays bas